Every day, it seems,
there's a new, bewildering
or frightening story
about AI in the news -
how it's going to steal our jobs,
spread internet fakery
on a colossal scale
and generally take over the world.
But what exactly is AI -
artificial intelligence -
and are the scare stories even true?
So, the first thing
to know is that AI has been around
a lot longer than you might think.
Its roots lie in an idea known
as an "artificial neural network"
from the 1940s.
A neural network is a bit like
a team of interconnected workers
that learn to solve problems.
Each time they come up with
a possible solution, it's marked.
If there is room for improvement,
they adjust and change
their connections.
Over time the network
becomes more efficient.
And technology powered by neural
networks is all around us right now.
It suggests movies and music
we might like.
It recognises faces and objects
when taking photos on smartphones,
enabling features
like facial recognition.
It's heavily used by social media
platforms to personalise our feeds.
More recently, a form of AI
known as "generative AI"
is powering applications that
can seemingly create new data.
It can also power chatbots like
Open AI's ChatGPT and Google's Bard,
which give humanlike responses
to questions.
These are getting better
at interacting with us,
and seemingly more humanlike.
This can seem scary,
but it's worth knowing point two.
If you ask ChatGPT
a question like this one -
"Why should we be concerned
about AI?" -
it does a pretty good job
of providing a response
that appears logical.
And with that convincing
humanlike response,
it's easy for us to believe
it understands what it's saying,
that it has feelings
and motivations.
It's understandable
that we do this,
but it's worth remembering,
right now AI can't think or feel,
can't love or hate.
ChatGPT and its counterparts
are sophisticated
sentence completion apps
that analyse our patterns
of communication
and provide responses similar to the
way humans would typically reply.
A bit like a "talking" parrot.
Which leads us
to point number three.
Chatbots can have an
awkward relationship with the truth,
technically known
as "AI hallucinations".
You could also describe it
as "making stuff up".
The core of the technology
is a model that uses probability
to predict the next word,
sentence or paragraph.
It can generate seemingly plausible
replies, but lacks the ability
to assess truthfulness
or the accuracy of its responses.
So anyone thinking of using
chatbots to write content
needs to be careful
they're not incorporating
credible-sounding BS
that can be easily spotted
by someone
who's actually done the research.
The idea of a racist machine
might seem far-fetched.
But if AI is trained on data
that's racist, biased or hateful,
then its output will be too.
As we all know, racism, bias
and hateful content can be found
in abundance online.
In 2016, Microsoft launched
an experimental chatbot called Tay,
but quickly pulled the plug
after it made racist
and offensive remarks.
It learnt to do this
from interacting with users
on social media.
Microsoft apologised
and promised to implement improved
safety features in future.
This is why the ethical framework
that governs any AI application
is incredibly important, and why
many are calling for safeguards
to prevent bias and hate speech
to be built into AI systems.
For all the notes of caution,
it can be easy to forget
there's many
potential benefits to AI.
It's set to truly revolutionise
healthcare.
AI has already discovered new drugs
and is being used to identify
cancer cells
much more reliably than humans.
And AI chatbots can behave
like patient teachers
when we struggle to understand
a complex topic,
summarising huge volumes
of information for us.
The AI revolution has the potential
to enhance and speed up work
in many fields, from software
programming, to animation,
to law enforcement and journalism.
This has pluses and minuses,
of course,
but could this extra capacity
free us up to do other things?
Like tackling climate change
or looking after ourselves
and each other better?
As AI advances, governments
and regulators will of course
need to make sure it's being used
ethically and legally -
no easy feat.
But will AI take over the world?
Don't forget, AI is a tool,
and even a powerful tool can't
take over the world on its own.
It's up to us to decide
how we use it -
or even if we should use it at all.